[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild morgens um 7 Uhr am 18 August
1988 steuert ein BMW
735i mit dem niederländischen
Kennzeichen
hr20tn auf den Grenzübergang kleiner
bururg bei Gronau zu im Auto sitzen die
Geiselnehmer Dieter digowski Hans Jürgen
Rösner und Marion löblich sowie ihre
Geiseln es handelt sich um Silke Bischof
18 Jahre in der Ausbildung zur
rechtsanwaltsgehilfen und ihre
langjährige und beste Freundin Ines
feutle Azubi als Verkäuferin beide
kommen aus Bremen und sie sollen an
diesem dritten Tag des Dr
eine tragische Rolle spielen ich bin
Stefan Netzeband hallo und mein Name ist
Mirko Kasimir hallo und wir begrüßen
euch zum zweiten Teil dieser
Episode die Berufsverbrecher Rösner und
digowski haben zwei Tage zuvor eine Bank
im nordrheinwestfälischen Gladbeck
überfallen und dort zunächst zwei
Angestellte als Geiseln genommen aus
ihrer Flucht wurde eine tödliche
Irrfahrt die mittlerweile das ganze Land
in Atem hält noch in Gladbeck holten die
gangngster rösners Freundin Marion
löblich ins Auto in Bremen karperten sie
einen Bus auf einer Raststätte
erschossen sie eine Geisel und zwar den
14-jährigen Schüler Emanuele di Georgi
der seine kleine Schwester beschützen
wollte auf dem Weg zum Einsatz ist bei
diesem Drama auch noch ein Polizist
tödlich im Auto verunglückt und bei
einem Missgeschick in Holland löste sich
bei Geiselnehmer Rösner ein Schuss der
seine Freundin ins Bein traf vor allem
leistet sich die Polizei eine Blamage
nach der anderen während eine Schar
enthemmter Journalisten den Entführern
folgt wie einem Irren Wanderzirkus
dieser Fall ist eine einzige tödliche
Katastrophe und sie steuert an diesem 18
August
1988 auf ihren absoluten Tiefpunkt zu
weil Marion löblich verletzt worden ist
rechnen die Behörden auf
nordrhein-westfählischer Seite damit
dass die Entführer das grenznahe
Krankenhaus in Gronau
ansteuern aber sie irren sich der BMW
steuert über Münster Köln an bei einem
Zwischenstopp in Wuppertal kaufen die
Entführer unter anderem neue Medikamente
und Proviant ein schließlich erreicht
der Wagen mit seinen fünf Insassen die
Innenstadt von Köln und bleibt in einer
Fußgängerzone stehen wieder umringen
Journalisten das Fahrzeug wieder
schreitet die Polizei nicht ansatzweise
ein und so steht Hans-jürgen Rösner
wieder in seiner ganzen schlichten
dämlichen
kamer und gibt den coolen
bösewichtagen was gestern passiert ist
in Bremen und sonst
ja
BU türkischen L mit Polizei gesprochen
nicht weiter wir wollten unbedingt dass
die Frau unter der Kassierer
von
freel und überall und habe ich in die
Luft geschossen und so zweimal ne und
ich hatte noch eine Polizeipistole bei
die habe ich einen in Gladbeck auf der
her Straße an Tankstelle habe ich den
Pistole weggenommen den Polizist wissen
sie und die habe ich dann auch mal
nebenbei gleich ausprobiert so ne ja und
dann sind wir in den Bus rein der wollte
wegfahren habe ich gesagt stehen bleiben
ne sonst Knall und hat er auch gemacht
und da sind wir rein habe ich gesagt es
passiert kein was hier verhaltet euch
ruhig ne und haben sie auch soweit
ja dann war der ganze Auflauf da Polizei
und neugierige Leute dann ging es auf
einmal
schief ja und dann haben wir habe ich
gewwartet dass endlich einer kommt mit
dem wir verhandeln kann ne der Polizist
der der Reporter oder Journalist was das
war war übrigens ganzen linken ne der
sagte ich werde da versuchen zu
vermitteln ist auch rübergegang zur
Polizei da und hat gefragt und haben sie
gesagt hier nein es kommt kein Polizist
rüber ne immer wieder Filmen die Kameras
auch die beiden verängstigten Geiseln
die bildhübsche blonde Silke Bischof die
mal verlegen mal ängstlich guckt und
dann in einer Art fassungslosen
Ratlosigkeit auch lächelt und ihre etwas
kräftigere Freundin Ines die sich um sie
sorgt haben sich Journalisten in diesen
Tagen unfreiwillig und aus
Sensationsgier gar zu Komplizen der
Täter gemacht Bildreporter Peter hell na
ja man muss sagen das war ein Novum was
ich da abgespielt hat das gab es weder
in der polizeitaktischen Führung noch
unter Journalisten in Medien dass man
eben Freihaus ein so dramatisches
Ereignis geliefert bekommen hat zwei
Geiselnehmer sitzen im Auto mit Geiseln
und lassen zu dass Zivilisten Passanten
und eben auch Journalisten quasi an das
Auto rankommen das hatte einen Grund die
Geiselnehmer haben natürlich die
Öffentlichkeit und die Journalisten als
Schutz benutzt weil sie wussten dann
kann es keinen Zugriff geben und sie
haben natürlich dann auch über die Medi
Forderung verbreitet und sie konnten
dadurch natürlich auch quasi das
Geschehen selber lenken was für die
Polizei eine Katastrophe ist und für die
Journalisten in dem Falle in
Anführungsstrichen ein Glücksfall war
weil sie natürlich sehr nah an dieser
Situation dran war so wie das sich
damals gezeigt hatte und gezeigt hat so
würde es heute nicht mehr
passieren was Journalisten ob vom
Fernsehen oder den Zeitungen ob von
Privatsendern oder der ARD an diesem Tag
in Köln für ein Bild abgeben ist eine
wahre Schande sie drängen sich um den
Wagen um ein Interview zu bekommen
halten sie der Geisel doch bitte noch
mal die Knarre an den Kopf bitet ein
Fotograf die Entführer besonders schwer
ist es im Rückblick die Stimme von Sicke
Bischof zu hören wie geht's ih ja gut
also ich habe es Angst davor dass die
Polizei nicht darauf eingeht und das
noch mal soas passiert umgebracht hat
oder so ich habe hier Geisel und äh
nicht
daran es ist schwer die Stimme von Silke
Bischof zu hören weil man sie heute
nichts mehr Fragen kann nicht fragen
kann was sie wirklich dachte wie geht es
ihn mit der Pistole am eigentlich
ziemlich gut dafür mir alles gar bewusst
so jung könen Sie sich vorstellen
wirklich auch
bildfreorter von damals nur schwer
ertragen denn in der Nähe die die
Journalisten zu den Tätern hatten lag
für die Polizei eigentlich auch eine
Gelegenheit findet er dann hat sich etwa
ja wie ein Rausch entwickelt unter den
Journalisten jeder wollte nah dran sein
der Höhepunkt traurige hörepunkt war
dann in der Kölner Fußgängerzone wie das
Auto umringt war aber da sagen ja auch
heute viele Experten auch damals
involvierte sek Beamte eigentlich hätten
wir das genau für uns nutzen können wir
hätten ja diese Medien waren ja wie ein
Tarnmantel für uns wir hätten uns ja
drunter mischen können als Fotografen
tarnt wir hätten ja die Täter außer
Gefecht setzen können vielleicht sogar
durch diese Tarnung als Journalisten
aber da hat man sich damals gegen
entschieden man hatte irgendwie einfach
Angst etwas falsch zu machen keiner
wollte die Entscheidung treffen aber was
die Journalisten damals gemacht haben
geht eben auch überhaupt nicht dass
dieser eine Journalist dann Verhandlung
mehr oder weniger geführt hat liegt aber
sicherlich auch wieder daran der hat es
wirklich gut gemeint weil er es nicht
verstehen konnte dass bei der Polizei
sich keiner gekümmert hat um nichts die
Täter wurden immer nervöser haben in die
Luft geschossen es war ja auch wirklich
mit anzusehen wie die wirklich immer
mehr die Nerven verlieren dann gab man
ja wohl diesen Journalisten eine Nummer
bei der Polizei D hat er ja da auch
damals von seinem Autotelefon angerufen
Handys gab es ja noch nicht und sagte
immer nur da geht keiner dran da geht
keiner dran also diese Bilder im Kopf zu
haben es war ein Totalversagen auf allen
Seiten muss man einfach so sagen
tatsächlich gab es sogar den Versuch in
Köln die Geiselnehmer zu überwältigen
und auszuschalten ein seek Beamter
namens Riner Kersting arbeitete sich mit
einem Team in civil an den Wagen heran
und verwickelte in ein Gespräch aber
weil die Einsatzleitung dem Team
jegliche Bewaffnung verboten hatte
entschied Kersting sich im letzten
Moment gegen den
Zugriff nach einiger Zeit wollen die
Entführer raus aus dem Zentrum also
machen sich wieder Journalisten bereit
dem BMW zu folgen und Udo Röbel vom
Kölner Express bietet sich an die
Verbrecher in ihren Auto aus der
Innenstadt zu lozen aus heutiger Sicht
absolut haarsträubend aber damals Bild
Chefreporter Peter hell macht sich sein
Urteil nicht so leicht das ist eine
individuelle Sache der Kollege der das
gemacht hat Udo Röbel hat sicherlich mit
besten Wissen und Gewissen da gehandelt
wahrscheinlich wollte er oder das wird
ja heute wahrscheinlich auch noch sagen
der Geiseln kein Schaden zufügen das ist
eine komplette Einzelsituation die es
heute so nicht mehr geben wird diese
verstopften Autobahn auch dieses
hinterherfahren auch das da würde ich
mich nicht freisprechen auch da würde
man selber hinterherfahren um dem zu
begegnen oder um das zu verhindern hat
ja auch die Polizei oder haben natürlich
auch oder hat die Öffentlichkeit auch
eine komplette Veränderung vorgenommen
es gibt dann das sieht man in Kriegen
sogenannte embedded Journalisten um eben
einen sogenannten Wildwuchs zu
verhindern besagter Reporter Udo Röbel
war später übrigens noch Chef unter
anderem von Bild und Bild am Sonntag so
viel Transparenz muss sein an diesem
Sommertag
1988 steigt er an der Raststätte
siegburgwest wo die geilelnehmer tanken
wieder aus Rösner fährt weiter Richtung
badonneev dort plant die Polizei den
Zugriff Werbung so Mirko hier ist jetzt
mal ein Buchtipp angesagt oh das ist
eine seh gute Idee ich suche nämlich
noch Weihnachtsgeschenke ich auch mein
lieber und ich bin passenderweise auf
eine coole krimmi Reihe gestoßen od
jetzt machst du mich aber neugierig na
sag mal an ich schreib gleich mal mit
also alle Märchen Enden gut alle Märchen
Enden nee Stopp das ist nicht der Titel
aber was würdest du denn zu diesem Satz
sagen alle Märchen Enden gut na ja den
halte ich eher für ein Gerücht das
stimmt doch gar nicht dass alle Märchen
gut enden genau das ist eine Lüge und da
sind wir beim Titel Rotkäppchen lügt
heißt das Buch und mit dieser Lüge
beginnt der Auftakt einer TR ilogie von
Bestseller Autor Elias Haller der kommt
aus Moment Moment Moment warte warte von
dem habe ich gehört der ist Polizist
oder und der kommt aus meiner alten
Heimat Sachsen er kommt aus Chemnitz
glaube ich und er hat Bücher geschrieben
über einen Kommissar
namens Donner Erik Donner genau sehr gut
du bist gut Hall arbeitet seit 20 Jahren
als Polizist und jetzt gibt es eine
Reihe mit der Sonderermittlerin rotmann
vom Landeskriminalamt in Berlin die
stößt auf einen Korruptionsverdacht rund
um den früheren LKA Präsidenten und dann
bricht die Hölle los wie ein
blutdürstiger Wolf zieht ein Killer
durch die Hauptstadt Berlin erfügt sein
Opfern größtmögliche Schmerzen zu dabei
inszeniert er seine eigenen abartigen
märchenversion von Rotkäppchen denn
Rotkäppchen haben wir ja schon
festgestellt am Anfang Rotkäppchen hat
gelogen klingk sehr spannend und nach
einer guten Inspiration für Tatort
Deutschland das finde ich auch also
Fälle innerhalb der Polizei sollten wir
mal nach gucken hier noch mal zum
Mitschreiben Rotkäppchen lügt der Auftag
zur grimtrilogie von Elias Haller ist am
10 Oktober rausgekommen und wenn euer
Interesse jetzt geweckt ist holt euch
das Buch gerne bei Amazon oder klickt
einfach auf den Link in unseren Show
nototes Werbung
Ende gegen 11 Uhr am Vormittag hatten
die Geiselnehmer die Kölner Innenstadt
verlassen um etwa 13:35 Uhr erreichen
Sie über die A3 die Stadt batonev kurz
vor der Landesgrenze zu
Rheinlandpfalz am Autobahn Kilom 37,5
macht der Wagen einen Halt auf dem
Seitenstreifen als Rösner wieder vom
Standstreifen anfährt rammt das Kölner
Spezialeinsatzkommando den BMW mit einem
tonnenschweren Spezialwagen einer
umgebauten Mercedes
S-Klasse aber anders als geplant trifft
das SEK Fahrzeug nicht die fahrradtür
der Verbrecher sondern das linke
Hinterrad außerdem sollte eigentlich ein
Funksignal den Motor des präparierten
Fluchtwagens ausschalten richtig so eine
Art James Bond Logik aber das
Einsatzteam hat vergessen den
entsprechenden Sender mitzunehmen
entschuldigung das kann man nun wirklich
irgendwann nicht mehr fassen und so
endet die Polizeiarbeit wie sie die
ganze Zeit war während glutback völlig
Dilettant
der erste sek Wagen schrammt nach dem
touchieren am BMW vorbei weitere halten
an es kommt zu einem wilden
Schusswechsel in dem Durcheinander kann
Ines feutle fliehen digowski erleidet
einen Kreislaufkollaps und bekommt
nichts mehr mit Rösner schießt wild um
sich und trifft dabei Silke Bischof
tödlich er selbst überlebt genauso wie
seine Freundin und Komplizin Marion
löblich die beiden werfen ihre Waffen
aus dem Wagen und ergeben sich
54 Stunden nach Beginn des Dramas ist
die Geiselnahme von Gladbeck
beendet im Folgenden Gerichtsverfahren
werden Rösner und digowski zu
lebenslangen Freiheitsstrafen verurteilt
für Rößner ordnen die Richter darüber
hinaus die Sicherungsverwahrung an seine
Freundin Marion löblich erhält eineen
neunjährige Freiheitsstrafe wegen
erpresserischen Menschenraubs und
geiselname mit Todesfolge
aber wenn wir mal ehrlich sind dann war
damit nur ein kleiner Teil der
Geschehnisse geklärt die Polizei hat
sich damals 54 Stunden lang bis auf die
Knochen blamiert und die Journalisten
erwiesen sich als aktionistischer Haufen
ohne moralischen Kompass also hatte
Gladbeck Konsequenzen meint Bildreporter
Frank Schneider und meint in diesem Fall
erstmal die
Polizei jeden Tag sind in den sechs
großpräsidien die damals in nordfalen
dafür geschaffen wurden dann nach diesem
bladbecker Geiseldrama und diesem
verheerenden Fiasko die immer besetzt
sind und das sind auch die Standorte
nämlich Münster Bielefeld Köln
Düsseldorf Dortmund und Essen an denen
auch die Spezialeinheiten sitzen also
spricht das SEK was ist eben nicht nur
das SEK das Spezialeinsatzkommando
sondern es gibt auch noch ein emiga ein
mobiles Einsatzkommando was verdeckter
arbeiten kann was in so einem Fall auch
wegen der Verfolgung der Täter
unauffällig ganz wichtig wäre und es
gibt eben die Verhandlungsgruppe die
Verhandlungsgruppe sind geschulte
Polizeibeamte eben psychologisch gestult
die natürlich die Täter auch zur Aufgabe
besser bringen können oder sie besser
lesen können und dadurch natürlich die
Einsatzkräfte auch besser beraten können
und dann gibt's auch noch die technische
Einsatzgruppe die dann eben auch mit z.B
im Auto wo ein Sender dran ist oder eben
mit anderer Technik die natürlich heute
auch besser ist als damals muss man
fairerweise sagen aber natürlich auch
technisch unterstützen kann und diese
ständigen Stäbe sind jeden Tag da das
heißt egal wann etwas passiert es ist
ein ständiger Stab da und kann eine
sogenannte Bao nennt sich das ist eine
besondere Aufbauorganisation sofort im
Betrieb setzen und dann sind innerhalb
kürzester Zeit bis zu 500 Polizisten im
Einsatz weil man 100 schaffen
Spezialeinheiten alles verzahnt auch der
Journalismus hat aus kladbeck gelernt
das erste Ergebnis war eine Änderung des
Pressekodex beim Deutschen Presserat
seitdem sind Interviews mit Tätern
während des Tatgeschehens verboten
Polizei und Medien haben außerdem ihre
Zusammenarbeit besser geregelt sie
versuchen unter anderem wilde
Spekulationen mit Verbindungsbeamten und
schneller anberaumten Pressekonferenzen
einzudämmen aber Bildreporter Peter hell
sieht uns schon längst in den nächsten
großen
Herausforderungen der anderen Seite ist
es so dass was damals Gladbeck war
übernehmen heute die sozialen Medien und
jeder Bürger ist im Prinzip auch ein
Reporter denn wenn heute etwas
stattfindet findet dieselbe
Sensationslust und Gier auf der Straße
statt da werden die Handys gezückt und
da wird genauso nah rangegangen also
Gladbeck findet eigentlich heute bei
jeder kriminellen Tat jeden Tag statt
weil sobald Zeugen da sind übernimmt der
Bürger quasi als Reporter als filmender
die Rolle des Journalisten und insofern
gibt es gar keine Distanz mehr das hat
sich heutzutage so
verselbständigt dass teilweise und das
muss man auch leider sagen die Bürger
die Zeugen sind die Rolle der
Journalisten übernehmen und dass viele
Journalisten oder viele Zeitungen oder
Medienhäuser dann gar nicht mehr vor Ort
hingehen weil sie sagen wir haben ja
schon Bilder und wir haben ja schon
Informationen über die sozialen Medien
über Twitter oder x wie es Heus heißt
Instagram etc was journalistisch
eigentlich auch ein Sündenfall ist denn
da hat man gesehen dass da auch sehr
viele Fehler entstanden sind weil eben
nicht genug nachrecherchiert wurde oder
verifiziert wurde es wurde also an
verschiedenen Stellen gelernt aus dem
Drama von glattbeck aber längst gibt es
neue Herausforderungen bei kriminellen
Großlagen und damit sind wir am Ende
unseres heutigen falls angelangt wir
freuen uns dass ihr mit dabei wart diese
Doppelfolge haben wir mit dem Archiv von
Axel Springer und den fachlichen
Einschätzungen unser Reporter Peter hell
und Frank Schneider zusammengestellt
Aufnahme und Skript Stefan Netzeband
Schnitt Lilli von der Osten
Postproduktion durch schwarz audio
berlin wir hoffen wir hören uns auch
beim nächsten Mal bis dahin euer Mirko
und euer
Stefan
dir hat diese Folge von Tatort
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Rusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von ursela
Hermann wir hören uns bei tatout
Deutschland